[Música]
después que el ex militar
y las formas y el contexto militar me
sedujo rápidamente porque la
capacitación de base para aquellos que
quieren ser soldados dura 12 semanas me
pareció importante seguir esta formación
de corta duración porque me iba a
permitir filmar la transformación estos
jóvenes llegan como civiles con sus
valijas y dos o tres días después tienen
sus uniformes de combate los hombres se
hacen rapar el cabello es una
transformación visual muy rápida como es
un film de observación esos cambios
eran muy interesantes en el contexto de
un proceso de elección de una carrera
profesional además en el marco militar
esa decisión profesional implica también
cambiar de casa por 12 semanas
inicialmente duermen ahí comen ahí se
convierten en soldados ahí de alguna
manera se convierten en prisioneros de
esa decisión durante esas semanas y para
mí como realizador es muy interesante
porque están ahí disponibles para ser
filmados
esta información
interesante es quizá un peso son
disponiendo y son por qué
[Música]